[Applaudissements]
obtenu autant une ville dans le rythme
en conduite par vincent chauvet 2764
bois 52,1 des applaudissements nourris
et des militants masqués mais ravis dans
la foule le premier soutien de vincent
chauvet aujourd'hui policiers le député
rémy rebeyrotte
c'est à lui qui avait succédé le jeune
maire sortant gaudin qui garde son
fauteuil
mais le gagne aussi c'est toujours le
conseil municipal qui élit le maire et
en 2017 la loi sur le non-cumul afin que
le conseil municipal m'a élu cette fois
le conseil municipal va mais lire mais
j'étais tête de liste et c'est sur mon
nom que les autunois ont voté et je suis
content qu'ils aient pu saluer le
travail réalisé pendant trois ans
pendant six ans avec l'ancienne équipe
j'étais adjoint au maire et puis qu'ils
nous fassent confiance sur les six
prochaines années
devant la permanence de son adversaire
le divers droite frédéric brochot des
applaudissements aussi est un peu
d'amertume pour le candidat arrivé avec
une courte avance de 58 voix au premier
tour
il ya eu 6 3 3 mois quasiment et le
confinement bas il a servi on le
constate au maire sortant a deux façons
qui a utilisé réellement cette période
qui a été très difficile au point de vue
sanitaire humainement et il a utilisé à
des fins électorales
à autun ce duel à suspense à remobiliser
les électeurs
la participation pour ce second tour a
fait un bond de plus de 10 points